Speaker 1: OK, this is really great.
For weeks now, I've been reminding you every
time we talk about Fox News criticizing that
various vaccine requirements at different
companies, I've been reminding you.
Fox News has a stricter vaccine mandate than
the one that Joe Biden has proposed for companies
with 100 or more employees.
As we watched Tucker Carlson and Laura Ingraham
and Dan Bongino criticized the requirements
outlined by Joe Biden that all sorts of different
companies have adopted sports teams, airlines,
other organizations Fox News hosts would not
mention, Hey, our mandate here at Fox is even
stricter.
Joe Biden said get vaccinated or test weekly.
Fox News is doing get vaccinated or test daily
and wear a mask around other employees if
you're not vaccinated.
Fox News host wouldn't mention it.
They would just talk about vaccine mandates.
It's terrible.
They would mention, by the way, we work, it's
even stricter.
Last week, during his CNN town hall, which
we covered live, Joe Biden actually brought
this up.
Joe Biden actually said, Hey, you know, there's
this cynical, hypocritical fox coverage of
vaccination.
They have a mandate.
OK, so take a look at Joe Biden mentioning
that.
Speaker 3: You know what I find fascinating.
I turn on Fox to find out how popular I am.
But how are you doing there?
I'm doing very well.
I think I'm at three percent favorable, but
but all kidding aside, one of the things that
I find you realize they mandate vaccinations
at Fox headquarters.
Yeah.
I find that mildly fascinating and mildly
mildly fascinating.
Speaker 1: Now that is absolutely true.
They mandate with the option of testing out
just like Joe Biden proposed, except at Fox.
If you want to test out, you've got a test
daily instead of weekly.
This now pushed Fox News into needing to comment
on it.
They can't just pretend it's not going on,
and their reaction is just to lie and play
a meaningless semantic game that is completely
bogus.
So take a look at what the Fox and Friends
crew said the next morning about their own
mandate and the misinformation he said about
Fox.
Speaker 3: He thought it was crazy.
I think it's funny that Fox has a vaccine
mandate.
You have a testing option at Fox.
So what he said is totally inaccurate.
We don't have a mandate.
We have a protocol, right?
That's a little different
Speaker 1: from what you tell the president.
We don't have a mandate here, says Steve Doocy.
We have a protocol.
Why?
Because you can test instead of getting vaccinated.
But that's exactly what Joe Biden proposed.
Joe Biden said vaccinated or test weekly.
And Fox says vaccinate or test daily and wear
a mask.
And here's why it's not a mandate, but it's
a protocol is so silly.
Just look at what the words mean.
A mandate is an official order or a commission
to do something.
Well, Joe Biden's order is you vaccinated
or test weekly?
So by that definition, it's a mandate.
Fox News.
This order is vaccinator Tess Daly.
That's a mandate.
By this definition, it's a mandate.
Now a protocol is the accepted or established
code of procedure or behavior in a group,
organization or situation.
OK, so let's look at protocol.
Joe Biden's establish code of procedure is
that you vaccinated or you test weekly.
It's a protocol Fox News is established.
Code of procedure is you vaccinate or you
test daily.
It's a protocol.
They are both mandates of a particular protocol.
This is meaningless semantic trash.
And I tweeted about this over the weekend,
I said.
So apparently, Biden's required vaccine or
required weekly testing is a mandate.
But Fox News is required vaccine or required.
Daily testing is a protocol, and I received
a ton of really great responses.
But one Twitter user did he track one lays,
lays it out the way that I did here, saying
a protocol and a mandate are synonymous.
Both mean something has to happen.
Policy is also synonymous with mandate and
protocol, and that is exactly correct.
So this shouldn't surprise us.
These are just hypocrites.
These are people who mostly want to keep their
jobs.
Even as Dan Bongino was saying, I may quit.
Dan Bongino thing with I think it was Cumulus
Radio Networks are, though it may be a he
has a show on Fox and a show with a radio
network.
It might be Cumulus.
He was saying, Listen, I'm vaccinated, but
I'm against any vaccine requirements, so I
may quit my job here, depending on what happens.
He hasn't mentioned the fact that he's also
an employee at Fox, which has one of the strictest
requirements.
Now there are some employers that have gone
further and they've said, we just don't want
to deal with the testing or we don't want
to offer a testing option.
We just want everybody vaccinated.
That's it.
And certainly that's their prerogative and
something they can legally do.
That's not actually what Joe Biden proposed
for companies of 100 or more employees.
And what Fox News has gone out of its way
to do is something that's even stricter.
I have a friend who recently started work
at a at a West Coast, West Coast based startup.
And during the hiring process, even right
there when you apply, it says everybody on
our staff has to be fully vaccinated.
This allows us to do in-person events where
we can.
We just test everybody on the way in and we've
got these two layers.
Everybody's vaccinated and tested.
We can do stuff and they do do things.
Just don't apply if you're not willing, if
you're not willing to be fully vaccinated
by the time you start, just don't apply.
And much like, Hey, this job requires you
to work two overnights a week.
Oh, I don't want that.
I'm not going to apply.
Fine, you're being you're told up front that
is something companies can certainly do, but
that's not even what's actually being discussed
when we talk about the Joe Biden requirement.
So it's great that Joe Biden mentioning it
during the town hall Thursday pushed Fox hosts
to start talking about it.
Their reaction is so bogus, their explanation
is so pathetic and and saman, it's semantics
at the end.
It shouldn't really surprise us, and we'll
see.
My guess is that there's going to be more
commentary on this from them.